calafate a word you might be hearing a
lot lately Caliphate Caliphate caliphate
caliphate not elephant ever since the
group ISIL now called the Islamic state
announced it was establishing its very
own Caliphate in the territories it
controls in Syria and Iraq but what in
the world is a Caliphate let's go back
in time after the death of the Prophet
Muhammad the men who took over as
leaders of the Muslim faith were called
caliphs in Arabic the word means
successor and over the centuries as
Islam spread as far west as Spain and as
far east as China the areas under the
caliphs rule became known as the
Caliphate basically a Muslim Empire
there were many caliphates throughout
history and they were responsible for
some huge advances in science math and
medicine but like all empires they also
had their Wars of conquests Wars of
succession and just plain wars with one
another the last person to officially
hold the title of caliph with Abdul
Majeed the second the last Sultan of the
Ottoman Empire which ended in 1924 now
back to the self-proclaimed Caliphate of
the artist formerly known as ISIL who is
their caliph Abu Bakr al-baghdadi who
finally made a public appearance last
week rocking a very blinged out watch
way to keep it real he called on all
Muslims around the world to obey Him as
their leaders to which many responded
chill it's the middle of Ramadan and
were focused on the World Cup and even
though the caliphates of yesteryear do
share this pseudo faiths violent
tendencies some also had education
culture and open intellectual debate the
Islamic state on the other hand has
taken to destroying shrines statues and
debate come again but with only a few
thousand fighters and surrounded by
powerful enemies could all this
Caliphate business be too much too soon
you
[Music]
[Applause]